nichts verschwenden nichts vergolden
Menschen die sind inflations- und
Krisenzeiten ist das doch besonders
wichtig ja sie kennen das ja aber unser
Staat der verschleudert munter weiter
Millionen der Bund der Steuerzahler der
hat die schlimmsten aller
Verschwendungen jetzt mal wieder
aufgedeckt unfassbar muss man sagen
sie ist das neueste Beispiel für
Steuerverschwendung die Erweiterung des
Kanzleramtes für 777 Millionen Euro
sollen an der Spree weitere hunderte
Regierungsbüros gebaut werden inklusive
eines Hubschrauberlandeplatzes auf
Stelzen das zeigt es bleibt wichtig dem
Start beim Geld ausgeben auf die Finger
zu schauen Beispiele für
Steuerverschwendungen gibt es im
Schwarzbuch 2022 genug ja es ist immer
wieder das gleiche Muster wenn fremdes
Geld für fremde Dinge ausgegeben wird
dann scheint die Hemmschwelle sehr
niedrig zu sein deswegen müssen wir auch
strukturell etwas verändern ein
Kreisverkehr der Zu klein gebaut worden
ist in engelsbach Südhessen wird für
125.000 Euro ein Kreisverkehr mit einem
Durchmesser von 17 Metern gebaut um das
die lokalen Busse 24 Meter benötigen
also muss der Kreisel für weitere 75.000
Euro umgebaut werden die Beheizung des
heilig Steaks in Traunstein sorgt
ebenfalls für einen Eintrag in
Schwarzbuch 2022 eine beheizte Brücke
Sie haben richtig gehört die Fußgänger
und Fahrradbrücke kostet satte 2
Millionen Euro der Heizungsbau alleine
kostet 150.000 € und der Stromverbrauch
lag bei rund 23.000 € pro Jahr berechnet
nach den alten Preisen natürlich der
Oberbürgermeister entschied sich
mittlerweile die Heizung nicht mehr zu
nutzen Politik erzählt uns viel wie wir
duschen wie werden Waschlappen
gebrauchen müssen und so weiter aber
selber ist keine Vorbildfunktion zu
erkennen und das glaube ich regt die
Menschen sehr auf und vor dem
Hintergrund muss Politik jetzt auch
selber bei sich anfangen wir brauchen
eine Sparliste um eben auch die
Wahrhaftigkeit in der Politik erkennen
zu können was ich jetzt zur Zeit erlebe
dass es sehr viel wasserpredigen aber
Wein trinken das geht so nicht weiter
während Energie Spar Kampagnen uns zur
Sparsamkeit erziehen wir wollen zahlt
der Bundestag
12.500 Euro pro Tag für diese Lasershow
in Berlin
27.000 Kilowattstunden werden für die
Lichtershow verbraucht die ein
Bildungsprojekt sein sollen apropos
Bundestag trotz Sommerpause macht man
hier keine Pause beim Geld ausgeben die
Parlamentsgebäude sind in der Ferienzeit
hell beleuchtet und stets auf 22 Grad
gekühlt
50.000 Euro kostet das nach
Bildberechnung Fazit sparen hat in
normalen Zeiten nicht funktioniert und
funktioniert auch in diesen Krisenzeiten
leider nicht
Steuergeldverschwendung auch in diesen
Zeiten und dazu unser Bild
politikreporter Viktor Wachs bei uns im
Studio der Zahl steuern und er wird
nicht von ihren Steuern bezahlt und regt
sich erst recht in diesen Zeiten richtig
drüber auf dass die Politik offenbar
nicht kapiert hat dass es jetzt erst
recht ums Geld zusammenhalten geht genau
wir haben eine riesenkrise wir haben
Krieg in Europa wir haben eine Inflation
und die Politik macht einfach weiter
damit Steuergeld rauszublasen als gibt
keinen Morgen mehr und ich finde das
einfach nur unglaubliche Frechheit und
deswegen Kai finde ich dass es ein
bisschen mehr wie in der Wirtschaft
geregelt werden sollte bei den
Politikern und Sie sollten haftbar
gemacht werden für die Entscheidung die
Sie treffen die geben da nicht ihr
eigenes Geld ausgegeben unser aller Geld
aus und das geht nicht das heißt haftbar
machen was meinst du genau damit was
stellst du dir vor was könnte man ändern
naja viel lieben wir jetzt hier Mist
erzählen zum Beispiel im Studio dann
müssen wir uns dafür rechtfertigen
gegenüber unserem Arbeitgeber so geht es
den meisten deutschen aber politiker
können irgendein Großprojekt anstoßen
dann in den Sand setzen und sich dann
aus dem Staub machen ohne das hinterher
jemand sagt das geht nicht was hast du
da steh uns mal Rede und Antwort für die
Entscheidung die Du da getroffen hast
zum Beispiel der Berliner Flughafen BER
ein riesen Desaster milliarden wurden da
ausgegeben und dann haben sich die
Länder Brandenburg Berlin und der Bund
das gegenseitig zugeschoben ja dann noch
mal ganz kurz gehen konkret
kanzleramtsausbau also dieses neue
riesige Kanzleramt was ausgerechnet
jetzt wo es an Wohnungen weiterhin
natürlich fehlt wo äh die Mieten so
lange gestiegen sind da baut das
Kanzleramt sich eben sozusagen das
Doppelte Häuschen ganz konkret darauf
bezogen der Kanzler hat sich von
Bundestag beschließen lassen und jetzt
könnte er es ja auch stoppen also wäre
das so eine Frage von Haftung er müsste
jetzt sagen nur mache ich nicht und der
Bundestag muss das beschließen genau er
könnte jetzt sagen wir haben uns das
angeschaut er hat die
Richtlinienkompetenz das haben wir jetzt
gesehen er könnte jetzt sagen wir machen
das alles rückgängig diese Entscheidung
für diesen Protz Klotz hinten am
Kanzleramt für 777 Millionen Euro
Steuergeld wurde getroffen als es
Deutschland besser ging das ist jetzt
vorbei und deswegen waren wir das jetzt
nicht mehr aber nein es gibt jetzt ein
Hel Roboter Platz für 10 Millionen auf
Stelzen die 23 Meter hoch sind obwohl
das Kanzleramt schon ein heli-platz hat
also es muss alles nicht sein sagt Karl
Viktor Wachs danke schön für deine
Einschätzung
[Musik]